good morning Hank it's Sunday it's
Newsday and today I'm going to discuss
the rumored demise of the you in YouTube
but first important messages for
nerdfighters in Philadelphia or
Australia I'm going to be talking and
signing copies of my books this Saturday
at the Philadelphia Book Festival at
3:30 p.m. more info in the sidebar and
there's going to be an awesome nerd
fight a stick nerdfighter gathering on
Sunday May 31st in Melbourne Australia
featuring me yay Australia so Hank you
might be wondering why I dressed up for
my video today it's because I'm trying
to make us more attractive to
advertisers but I'm not wearing any
pants you can't make me wear pants
advertisers Hank it's been widely
reported that this Thursday YouTube is
going to launch a major redesign of the
site that will emphasize professional
content over user-generated content the
reports say that there will now be four
tabs there will be TV movies music and
then videos and then all of the
user-generated content will be in that
videos tab and so the site will begin
emphasizing more television shows and
feature-length movies and music videos
not so much because that's what people
want to watch but because that's what
advertisers want to advertise next to
and of course the entire YouTube
community is going to be furious about
this because well first because that's
what the YouTube community does it gets
furious and secondly they'll be furious
because this new redesign hurts the
little guy but it's strange to me that
we think that YouTube has a
responsibility to the little guy
corporations are not in the business of
being awesome they exist to make money
and according to almost every analyst on
Wall Street YouTube loses money
hand-over-fist
because it turns out that tens of
millions of people want to watch
squirrels waterskiing for free but it's
difficult to monetize those views
because Lucky Charms doesn't want to
associate their brand with waterskiing
squirrels advertisers want to be
associated with like American Dad and
bones so for the number of views that it
takes YouTube to make a dollar a site
like Hulu that features television shows
can make ten dollars so Hank I find it
hard to get mad at YouTube for wanting
to stop losing money but I am a little
bit mad at advertisers for thinking that
user generated content can't sell Lucky
Charms
I can sell Lucky Charms as well as
anybody Lucky Charms are like the
vampires of breakfast cereal their
magical they're delicious they're a
little bit dangerous and bad for you
you may initially make you feel great
but then over time you realize that
maybe your relationship with Lucky
Charms is just a little bit unhealthy
and you start to think maybe I don't
want to be in a long-term relationship
with a breakfast cereal that tastes
delicious but damages my health but then
the Lucky Charms gets all stalker on you
and for some reason you kind of like
that it makes you feel special so yeah
you spend your life with Lucky Charms
that's awesome that's a great way to get
diabetes Oh Hank I can't sell Lucky
Charms it's just not in me
so youtubers if you're going to get mad
that's okay but don't get mad at YouTube
from wanting to make money get mad at me
for being so bad at selling Lucky Charms
that said Hank there is one reported
change coming to YouTube that makes me
furious reports are that YouTube will
soon of a feature where you can dim all
the space like out there outside of the
video screen and I hate that idea what I
hate about television is that television
is something you watch what I love about
YouTube is that it's not television it's
something that you're called to
participate in my favorite thing about
YouTube isn't even what happens inside
of here my favorite thing is what
happens down there it looked like I was
pointing at my pants but I wasn't
pointing in my pants because I don't
have pants on I was pointing at the
comments and admittedly the quality of
discourse in many YouTube video comments
leaves a little bit to be desired but
for our community at least the comments
and video responses are a huge portion
of what goes on in these videos and I
hate the idea of making it possible to
dim the screen around you so you can
pretend you're watching television Hank
nerdfighters you're not watching
anything now let's continue this
conversation down below